[Music]
hello and welcome to South Korea I'm
here in Seoul that's all behind me
for kyrat carat 29 - which is a
conference all about renewable energy in
Asia it's basically all about renewable
energy uptake in Asia where we're at at
the moment and where we're going in the
future and with a heavy emphasis on how
can we try and accelerate this renewable
energy transition now you may well
wonder why am I at this conference and
the reason for that is ren21 ren21
by the way is the renewable energy
Network for the 21st century it's a well
hang on I interviewed somebody who can
explain this much better than I can
the idea of ren21 who was to create a
network a multi-stakeholder network
bring everybody together together with
ngos the science and academia and create
a network a global network on renewable
energy policy so it's a policy network
this is my hotel room by the way
pretty nice really I mean it's hotel
rooms are the same basically everywhere
something that is unique to this room
now I've never had this in a hotel room
before is um the throne it's got a
control panel I ran Google Translate
over the buttons and one of them
translate it to River one of the ones
over here translated to like limbs this
video is going to be a vlog about my
experiences the first time I've been to
Korea it's the furthest East I've ever
been actually but more than that I
expended about 880 kilograms of carbon
getting here and so about the same
amount getting back and I am trying to
fly as little as possible for the
foreseeable future and if I'm gonna
flown here and expended all that carbon
I don't have to make it worth it so
whilst I'm here as well as doing this
blog and sort of showing you about this
conference I'm going to be shooting some
stuff for other videos so I'm gonna be
interviewing some interesting people
from a variety of countries there's like
a hundred different nationalities
representative from across the world and
that's gonna go into future projects I'm
also going to be going out there
into Seoul and looking specifically at
the issue of renewable energy in Korea
but whose careers are an interesting
case when ren21 emailed me about this
conference the facts about korean energy
was what can't won me over to actually
coming and actually committing to
applying here and we'll learn about that
later on this video I can't tell you
everything right now that's stuck
[Music]
[Applause]
well that was kind of amazing water so
that opening session was basically the
same as any big conference like this
I've been to a couple before but this is
definitely the biggest you know heavy
hitters like the Korean energy minister
and the mayor of Seoul who both gave
really interesting speeches translated
on basically recognizing that climate
change was a massive issue and that they
wants to do something about it
however there was also really powerful
speech from could you say that but
you're not doing anything he may as well
have pointed at the Ministry of Energy
and say yeah you know what are you doing
but for me at least and I'm sure for a
lot of people in the room the massive
highlight was ban ki-moon was here who's
viewed Ono van ki-moon was the previous
United Nations secretary-general and was
the person pushed the Paris agreement
over the line basically a massive
climate hero and for me when I was at
school he had just been elected
secretary-general I think in 2007 when I
was doing a lot of Model United Nations
stuff so I was you know going to
conferences around the UK and pretending
to represent different countries he was
like the figurehead he was mr. UN and
especially with regards to the climate
stuff it was it was just a massive
privilege to see him in the room it was
it was really really cool initial
observations on career by the way I like
it here people are very friendly things
very clean apart from the air the air
pollution some really quite shockingly
bad something that I've noticed by the
way is that I think if it's just this
conference and every institution I've
been at in this country so far Koreans
really seem to like Jersey hold music
like between the sessions I've never had
a never seen this at any academic
conference before there's just like kind
of like saxophone piano bass light jazz
between sections
[Music]
it also happened on my bus from the
airport and I'm pretty sure in like what
hotel it kind of makes sense I know is
that a Korean thing as jazzy hold music
wherever possible just like a Korean
thing but following that we're now going
to come to the most important part of
any conference you know because of my
flight times yesterday I didn't actually
eat at all like I didn't have a single
meal yesterday so I'm making up for it
I'm having to eat salmon
I am pescetarian for those who keep
asking I try not to eat fish wherever I
can but sometimes like now you just have
to because there's literally I mean I
could just eat rice here but that is the
only vegetarian option everything else
is either meat or fish cultural
difference I guess
[Music]
so post-lunch
just saw one of the most interesting
plenary sessions I've ever seen all
talking about renewables being the new
name and the transition to 100%
renewables for not just electricity
generation but also for transport for
heating and basically how we can meet
the Paris agreement targets of by 2050
being net carbon zero the session
basically gave me a huge amount of hope
that you know as was the case in
Germany's and energy industry for
example it can be done and it can be
done very effectively and it just yeah a
lot of them have left by now filming
this but there were so many important
people in the energy industry from
around the world who were able to see
that discussion taking place and see
these people these experts saying yeah
I'm optimistic that we can do this I'm a
stubborn optimist it's gonna be
difficult but I think we can do it right
I prepare ice
[Music]
I think technically economically 100%
renewable future is possible even
probably before 2050 it is difficult
because there is so much sort of
interest driven energy policy which is
based on fossil and some partly even
nuclear fuels and that actually stops
and holds the the industry back
so technically economically no problem
politically no not yet but I think we
get there because at the end of the day
politicians will also realize that
renewables are simply cheaper to a
conference like this
they're bloody tiring especially when
you're jet-lagged so this afternoon
there was the first of the breakout
session so instead of having like
massive things in the big auditorium
which is up there they're in these small
rooms on this floor which was much more
specialized so I was just in a session
on how to make the renewable energy
transition inclusive in terms of gender
and in terms of wealth and that was an
interesting session there are a bunch of
interesting statistics on the fact that
renewable energy is actually a lot more
inclusive in terms of gender than
traditional energy so if you look at
like the distribution through the ratio
of men to women it's higher in
renewables by quite some distance but
not 50/50 so some power structures kind
of carry on what's happening now is this
the first evening of the conference
proper that was kind of like a warm-up
thing yesterday but this is the first
proper evening and so there's going to
be a cocktail reception which is being
put on by the conference organizers for
the bigwigs but also I get to go
[Music]
I could get used to this international
diploma today I think this is what
climate change deniers think that the
academic climate change gravy train
looks like not not all events I've never
been to an academic conference even
remotely like this just just so you know
you know I was thinking to myself today
can get any stranger we've had a massive
international conference I've got to see
ban ki-moon but to interview some really
interesting people
swanky dinner cocktail party the k-pop
group came out a k-pop group singing of
all things an Abba medley for an
audience of international energy
ministers he started dancing I know that
the jet lag is making me a bit woozy but
this is a weird right
welcome in a national painting I'm sure
if I was being a political animal about
this and I wanted to get to know people
I wanted to interview and maybe sway
some people I'd be in there still
talking but
I'm too tired man added deep eyes are
the best of time let alone where I'm jet
lag by eight hours right day - this is
like a big deal insecure about my gear
I'm not gonna like guys look at that
camera what you're doing this guy films
I'm just a guy with a DSLR and crippling
social anxiety that means I can't talk
to people I'm sick I can't compete with
the pros let this be a lesson to you if
you've ever intern somewhere a delight
work experience and you felt like you
were a bit demean like you won't being
used to your full potential at least you
are not
literally being used as a microphone
stand
thank you kneeling like man for your
service since it would be impossible
will they definitely just couldn't get a
delegate to hold the microphone
[Music]
so now the conference is done ren21
people can relax so I'm joining them I
have no idea where
[Laughter]
you just have to say that you're fine
when you're not really fine but you just
can't get into it because they would
never understand okay I am slightly
regretting putting so much there's jelly
on my plate
shame on you mystery lab food we're
about 45 minutes into the meal I think
at this point and we have so many dishes
and right now I have like this boiling
soup a tofu sandwich sure this is a fish
which I need have chopsticks to eat rice
mystery paste another mystery paste with
some little leaves
[Laughter]
very loud yes play tunes ends of the
game
you're very pretty very loud Oh Duncan
is incredibly sure that this to be the
Potter it's clearly it's an otter it's a
beaver rightly I thought it was a bear
it's a mere nature
[Music]
so didn't it was interesting like a
million different dishes per person it's
bit like camp Korean tap bus I guess I'm
waging like kind of she works around 21
which is awesome that thing is like a
liaison I was saying that you know if
you're cooking for more than a couple of
people that is how she would certainly
present the food so it was nice to kind
of get like a sense of okay on just
conference but what like what we know
what living in Korea is like so that was
cool he also had cats so we're currently
being guided to a undisclosed new
location tonight apparently when north
of the river in Seoul and that's
basically where it feels much more this
is where people live like the status
after the river where we were is a bit
like the city in London is like where a
lot of the big finance like a lot of the
big business and the wealth is
concentrated but this around us is
people's lives it feels like this city
at night is amazing it feels alive
[Music]
oh my goodness sniffing brain if you're
watching this so in the space of a
single block we've gone from one end of
the solar spectrum and like the most
neon I think I've ever seen in my life
in one place and then literally just
like two minutes down the road you did a
little bit of nature right in the middle
of the city it's quite eerie how come at
ambient light there is
[Music]
and it feels like there's a massive
sports stadium in every direction under
the bridge oh this is so pretty
much as we've been enjoying this nature
walk down here we've just been talking
about how the light pollution here I
don't know if you can tell the like it's
like a half 10:00 at night it should be
pitch black but because there's just so
many lights and the semi you know
massive lights on the tops of buildings
and the city is just so big it's never
gonna get any darker than this you know
like good luck ever trying to see the
stars and admittedly tonight is
particularly bad because there's a bunch
of low clouds but it's just never seen
anything like it not even not in the
center of London in all the big cities
I've been to it's quite extraordinary
it's predicted by the end of the century
that I think it's 80% of the human
population is gonna be in cities it's
about the night sky the 80 percent of
people are going to see
which one I find someone to get a drink
I think Absolut jungle down here
[Music]
so Korean builds almost entirely geared
towards science but um you can spec into
domination if you want
[Music]
so this is technically the last day of
the conference this is the cultural tour
that's been organized by the conference
convenors and we're coming here we're
going to two other places so this is a
fortress sort of south of Seoul proper
it was built around 1800 interesting for
a variety of reasons we just had a
really interesting tour and sort of
shown around some of the fortifications
one of the interesting things was about
70 percent of the fortress that you can
see behind me was destroyed in the
Korean War but the records when it was
built in the first place was so
meticulous they were able to recreate
exactly what it was so the point where
now it's the UNESCO World Heritage Site
is as good as a recreation is you could
have a sort of hope for compared to
European fortresses from well I suppose
that at this time it was Napoleonic so
certainly compared to um those
fortresses it's amazingly like richly
decorated it's pretty it's beautiful
here the other thing on tour guide
pointed out was that it works out on
average that Korea has had a war in it's
sort of recorded history on average once
every six months
like these people are really really
bloody sick of warfare in case you're
wondering why the walls are so low by
the way they're like five meters tall
it's because this is what - look us
looks like okay as I asked them mean
like Europeans looks like a medieval
fortress but this was built in an age of
cannon so having tall walls is like no
advantage it's just a bigger target
[Music]
so after the fortress we've come to a
temple I'll be very real with you I
don't really understand what's going on
no one's really explained very much to
the bat this is a temple and it's very
pretty look there's a lot of dynastic
stuff here look this is the sort of
central what's called audience chamber
and the whole the family that built all
this is good innit I've been listening
to the talk that I started really
understand what's happening right so I
actually paid attention for a bit and
friendly cracking code of why there are
so many side dishes yes but they let me
have that big meal it's because all the
dishes have like Korea Society energy
balance and there's like five different
kinds of energy is really important each
dish has an Associated energy and so
it's like trying to balance everything
so I trying to construct a balanced
Pokemon deck well done Simon is
reference from 1997
[Music]
one more stop on the tool and it's a
traditional village in the middle of
salt absolutely beautiful
[Music]
the general since I've had of being here
like now that we've gone a bit further
abroad than just the Convention Center
is that it kind of confirms what I
thought before which is that everyone
here is really polite as like respect to
the massive aspect and a particularly
respectful for elders is like a massive
thing here people are a lot more
measured I guess it's all so
meticulously clean I mean obviously this
is like a tourist trade place it
expected to be clean but I don't think
I've seen a single piece of litter or a
single piece of graffiti the entire time
like I've been here I've gotta say I
like it a lot
it's a shame I just wish pics without
could be here with me because you I'm
sure find all this very interesting in
this obviously there are people the
convention with me but like it's much
much more fun when you're traveling with
other people I think people that you
love I mean when it's like this it's
could be worse come on
[Music]
I have no idea this is gonna make it
into the vlog or not but I'm really
strict somehow I have no idea what was
posted by people's presence but this
evening is because so it's all the kids
are it's all taps
it's all tap or really expensive I
struggled buying presents for people at
the best of times but like I'm now
trying to do it in a language where I
can't even read the labels I half of the
stuff is even if I could read the labels
I'm pretty sure I still wouldn't know
what half this stuff is okay so we're
now having a look around the actual
historical village which is a bit more
what I expected it's kind of thing
[Music]
[Music]
it's amazing how cultures all over the
world come up with basically the same
lots of spiky things this is not so
creepy
[Music]
well that's pretty cool another
observation about Korea I have never
been anywhere where people have been so
willing to duck under the camera
whenever I have been filming here and
also at the conference everybody like
instead of getting in the way is just
ducked under the frame
wait would I be asking Turtles just been
like very hopefully this country to film
in like ever binge this village is
amazing by the way it's just so
fundamentally different it's like way if
I'm in England I go to like a
traditional village I can and there's
such hearts and something from like the
16th century or something like that you
can still relate to it on some level
because it's only different in some ways
here the like the the real fundamentals
like for example the alphabet like the
materials used like the philosophy
that's gone into all the buildings
everything is just so different it's
like it's kind of overwhelming how
completely different I don't wanna use
the word alien cuz that has negative
connotations I think it's really
interesting and like I'd love to learn
more we've had like five minutes here
it's just so different it's this is
amazing I kind of attempted to come back
to Korea now and actually have more time
here with Briggs we'll go thank you very
much to the conference team for setting
this up this has been a real highlight
oh hello ladies
[Music]
so it's the final date here Sunday
flying out tonight so I thought I'd do
something that I'd not had an
opportunity to do this whole time
starting so early it okay for a run and
just uh having a look around this temple
complex that you can see from the
Convention Center that's why it's if
myself interesting warning run I've ever
done it's amazing so for a temple you
know all this traditional work and then
when the most modern cities in the world
beautiful
well the main is a Han River that's the
big river that bisects Seoul it's really
significant in Korean culture because it
sort of represents the economic miracle
of the last century The Miracle on the
Han River
I think the miracle here is be reaching
it not dying because of all the hills
not dam you could really see the air
pollution this morning like that's a lot
of smog it doesn't feel bad in the lungs
you can just see it it's not as bad as I
thought it would be all right I'm gonna
run over the river and then back sit a
bit ha ok so I didn't know this was here
I just not over the bridge this big
thing and I was gonna just turn around
and go back but uh behind me
so you know autumn rain do you bench
press
apparently one of the exercises here is
run like a Minecraft character this is
also the first bit of green I've seen in
the city so I'm just gonna take
opportunity to run through it it's very
fruity how pretty is this alright tango
in the subway almost all of the
advertisement is too powerful capable
and what's interesting is a lot of
things on down there there's one here
these these are partly out there these
are post-it notes that people have put
up here this is like huge
[Music]